بالعوده حازم لتجربتك طبعا انت
امتحنت الاحزاب القوميه بشكل عام يعني من
داخلها ومن خارجها وكتبت فيها يعني كتبت
الكثير
وقراءات ربما تكون الاكثر عمقا لانك على
درايه بالتفاصيل فيها اكثر من سواك اذا
اردنا يعني الاشاره الى ايجابيات في هذه
التجارب
القليله في الكتب في التنظير
والى ايجابيات ايضا اسست عندك بعض الاسئله
الخاصه ربما
فينا نشير الى شيء اي تجربه باخر الامر
ممكن تغني
اللي تعلم الذي يتعلم يعني انا بدعي انه
في عدد كبير من الناس بعضهم بعرفهم شخصيا
اكبر اللي فيك تقدرهم
ماكينه حياته اخذت هالمسارات
[موسيقى]
القاسيه والتجارب المعاهده فيها
لو اتيح للمجتمعات تبعنا تكون مستقره اكثر
لو اتيح يكون في فكر ليبرالي اقوى
بمجتمعاتنا ما فيها شيء هذا التقليد موجود
يعني ضعيف
فبضطر ناس مثلي كثار بالمناسبه انه يفوتوا
بتجارب
ممكن تحطمهن في البعض يتحطموا التجارب
يعني بس كمان
فيك تحكي عن حياه اعداد اكبر كتير
كان حظهم اشوق
كان حزن اسوا
ودفعوا غالي
اذا بدك بالمحصله العامه لا لو بلاكي احسن
يعني